[Music]
[Applause]
our next guest longtime friends of the
program that said there was a point in
my life where one Mike gock was more
than enough and now we have two of them
and I better be careful because they
could easily beat me up they're probably
saving that for Mike Greenberg so please
welcome Mike gock and Mike goet
Jr oh my God
Mike Senior and Junior co-host of Gojo
and go on DraftKings Network Big Mike
little Mike although little Mike is Big
Mike yeah yeah it's it's changed um I
have a a bone to pick with you all
righty first off congratulations I just
saw a publication that said you're the
number one National Sports show in the
country Dan Patrick number one
okay that that's not the bone to pick
with you number two is is fritzy uh got
a hundred bucks for me and Mike for
being on the show he said we had to pay
to be on your show because you're number
one yes so what what the hell is that
I'm big now okay yeah no it's clearly
yeah all right Big Mike little
Mike big
Dan what I was known in high school is
Big Dan yeah in your mind right all
righty here they are uh good to see you
guys you too number one topic this week
is what now and what do you think it
will be by Super Bowl Mike where does
Taylor Swift fit into that uh right now
number one considering the Grammys last
night I would say I mean but the Tavis
thing has been the big story of most of
this season so I'd say that lead dogs
the week here and then we'll give way to
football as the week goes on yeah that's
always the interesting thing as
obviously Dan as you know as well it you
try and talk as little football in the
beginning of the week to kind of
Crescendo to
it though I will say in in doing shows
as I was listening you talked to Nicole
Arbok who's fantastic I immediately
started thinking of me and Mike's show
later on today going boy I'm going to
fight back on I start thinking of topics
to talk about anything but the Super
Bowl you know and still wait until later
in the week but also you have to play
the
hits as as we know being at ESPN they
tell you to play the hits there and
sometimes it's fun to just take you know
that off the beaten path and say let's
go down that road I think what's
happening in college football is I mean
it's going to be Transcendent it's going
to happen the question is when and what
is it going to look like your thoughts
on that you know I I looked at didn't we
as I heard Nicole talking didn't we have
the Pack 12 the Big 10 and the ACC all
arm in-arm saying we're all friends now
never forget the alliance until and how
great that was going to work until it
doesn't and everybody's on their own
then well I I look at the big 10 now in
the SEC as two prom Kings out there
saying hey let's take over the world
together until we're not until something
benefits one more than the other
especially when a Greg sanki is involved
because he's going to answer to nobody
so I always have a little trepidation
when I hear people are getting together
alliances are getting together I know
you feel differently that's the fun of
battling my young wrong
son that's I think we just all see where
this is going and it's one of those I
don't know how we get there but I'm
pretty sure I know where the destination
is and it's the one super conference to
rule them all that we've been whispering
about forever and when the two premier I
mean think about how long now we've
already been referencing it as the power
two in college football like it's the
big 10 in the sec's world at this point
and so the fact that the two prom Kings
have started talking at a time where
you've got lawsuits running rampant
where as soon as the NCAA tries to step
in and regulate anything regarding name
image and likeness of the changing world
the college football everyone's ready to
sue because they know there are attorney
generals that know that their
constituency is all going to love this
and you've got the higher courts that
are always going to rule in favor of
players and the schools are realizing
and the power conferences are realizing
hey we don't have to play by your rules
anymore because no one has power in this
sport it has existed largely lawlessly
for a long time the NCAA has tried to
come in every once in a while and Corral
stuff but it never really has been
governed by anyone and so there's a
great chance to create power out of
nowhere we're talking to Mike gock Senor
Mike gock Jr and the are the co-host of
Gojo and gock on DraftKings Network you
know Patrick Mahomes has gotten into
that category where we go we we did this
this morning before we came on we're
like how many conference championships
has he been to like when you start to
forget like LeBron Tom Brady wait
Brady's got oh seven Super Bowls like
you get into that category there and
that's when you know you've made it when
we forget how many you've been to how
many You've Won is Mahomes the second
greatest quarterback of all time right
now see I I I want to hold off on that
because me being you know one of the
older people how many people remember
John unitis or some of the great
quarterbacks back in the day
where ex exhibit realize you're going to
get a Johnny United reference there was
great quarterback play decades ago Sid
Luckman I remember him there was
football the year 2000 I mean but
seriously I get laughed at when I say
that but how do you judge all of that
right we're in a stats world now but
about ability greatest mean you you look
at athletes back in the day to now
they're just better athletes and but
that always doesn't make them better but
with Pat you're getting that rare
combination of he's better athlete than
a lot of quarterbacks and better than a
lot of quarterbacks am I going to put
him in the top two right now no I'm
going to wait because I'm going to give
the players before him the benefit of
the doubt of their longevity okay Pat's
been great right out of the gate but
let's let's let it continue to happen
he's I don't know if he'll get to to
Tom's statistical area of of postseasons
and Super Bowls so I'm going to wait on
that but look I I'll put it this way
he's in the team picture right now with
but with their longevity most of them
have not accomplished what he's done and
the way he's done it and that's always
the differentiator for me is because
we're going to have a very and some
people call it lazy the comparison with
Tom Brady and US wanting to FastTrack
him for that but that's earned not given
like you pointed out he's 28 and we're
already forgetting stuff that he did
that's insane it shouldn't be happening
and because of that and because he's
been the driving force this has been the
first year where it's like oh they're
you know defense and a run game and
Pat's got to make plays every once in a
while it was him to start he was the
thing that drove the ship out of the
gate and is now getting the Cavalry to
come help which is why I think he
deserves a lot more place in that
conversation than maybe you want to give
him we were talking about this this
morning as well that in 20 years from
now do we do we find those Kansas City
Chiefs who were kind of it it was spawn
on now in the last 5 years or so or even
now with Taylor Swift and Travis Kelce
like it was with the Cowboys in the 70s
Packers in the 60s a lot of our uh fan
bases are based off what happened in the
70s the 60s Steelers Cowboys Packers
ners right and now you have the the
Kansas City Chiefs the Patriots were
never America's team no uh Boston's team
but never America's team but is Kansas
City capable of being America's team
well I I think be part of it is how are
you looked at are you looked at as
somebody you want to see beaten or are
you looking at like I like these people
bill you know you know doing his press
conferences he wasn't endearing himself
to anybody Tom was doing it the bill
bich way and not saying anything until
he got to Tampa Bay and then all of a
sudden he broke out a little bit who who
doesn't love Andy Reid by the way Andy's
not getting enough talk either this
guy's walking straight into the Hall of
Fame as well for what he's doing momes
is fun Travis Kelce has always been fun
now the whole Taylor Swift thing as well
they're kind of a fun team to follow but
Dan you know this we've been doing this
a long time you love a team on the rise
and when they're at the top for a little
bit and then man you want to see darts
throwing at them you want to see them
come crashing down it's like when you
have your favorite band you know I
remember seeing them at Toad's Place and
then all of a sudden they're like you
know they're they're playing the garden
I hate them now exactly exactly so I I
think but I do think they are really
likable right now even lovable to a
point especially the whole Taylor Swift
thing has added in there I've been so
disgusted with our football people who
have had a problem with that I'm just
like God leave it alone why do people
have a problem I have no idea do do you
remember when Jessica Simpson was
showing all the time when she was dating
Tony Romo we never heard any of this she
wasn't shown nearly enough no no there
you go we also did hear a lot of this
back then by the way PE people have
never the like knuckle dragging football
crowd has never really liked women
invading their space in any meaningful
way they go to
Cancun Scandal he's not focused on the
game but but that was the quarterback of
the Cowboys going to Cancun and he
costed the Cowboys you know in their
mind like you know your your mind should
be on football you know Taylor doesn't
show up and say Hey you know I haven't
been on camera in a while exactly yeah
you know CBS shows Robert Craft a couple
of times every game or Jerry Jones every
game and are we really better off for
that I don't need to see them exactly
and oh by the way for everybody out
there Travis Kel's numbers with Taylor
there are better than his numbers
without Taylor there okay Taylor just so
set that up and set of people saying oh
she shows up and Travis plays bad no he
doesn't though he did have two drops in
the last game where do you stand on this
as as we move she might be a villain
here if Kansas City loses she I mean she
was when they went to Baltimore too like
that was finally the fan base that was
like oh yeah no we're uh we're going to
throw rocks at this whole situation
which I get it's this point in the
postseason they are the team and to
Dad's point about what they're going to
represent to a lot of people like I
don't know if we're going to get to a
point where anyone can really be
America's team anymore because
everyone's so exposed now for these guys
theirs is different because he's
transcended like I would Sports stories
you guys have seen break contain at some
point when you start to see them talked
about on GMA and the shows that are
outside of our bubble they've broken
contain both with this relationship and
with that combination of in a helmet
sport Travis has been one of the guys
whose face you've gotten to know because
of the podcast because of the
relationship and so they've got a chance
to reach more casual eyeballs than most
but I I think because everyone's so
exposed and because these guys are now
the stopper on top of a conference for a
lot of people I.E Buffalo whose
happiness is being really affected by
the fact that Patrick Mahomes and these
Chiefs exist I find it interesting that
this is probably the best matchup but
the matchup that we didn't want that
they didn't have the story lines that I
think if Buffalo was here against
Detroit people would be more excited
excited even though these are probably
the two best teams but it's weird how
we're like yeah didn't we see this a
couple of years ago yeah we did we saw a
Kansas City win there I I think one of
the interesting things and we had Mike
and I had Richard Sherman on our show
and he talked about everybody loves a
good Underdog Story except for Brock pie
for some reason Brock pie who has been
doing great out there we can't give him
the love because you say oh he's got
four or five people to Dish the ball out
to well yeah so what most most most
players have great players around them
as as well but I'm with you because
we're going to talk about Mahomes we're
going to talk about Brock pie but this
like the AFC Championship Game could be
a game talked about on defense and
that's like a swear word to anybody else
except for like me a former defensive
player I love seeing great defense and
you may get that here yeah I think that
having that Underdog of if Buffalo and
Detroit somebody's going to get their
first Super Bowl right and and I and
it's interesting though that people are
like you know there's no buzz here but
these are the two best teams they are
and it feels like uh the media will
probably you know enhance the Taylor
Swift thing because maybe we've been
down this road with all these different
storylines with momes with Kelce but the
Brock py won he didn't get this chance
last year now he gets this chance and
I've said before I think he's got to win
two Super Bowls Mike before people will
give him credit not one I think they'll
go okay all right let me see you do it
again it it we went through this with
pton Manning right I mean and it still
blows my mind and I know it's a topic
nobody cares to discuss why do we put
Super Bowl wins with quarterbacks when
there's offense defense special teams
wins and losses I never understood that
but regardless of what I think that's
where we are I mean it comes down to the
number so I think they could have been
there last year Brock py doesn't get his
elbow hurt but I'm with you you know
nowadays for quarterbacks we keep
talking about that with Aaron roggers
right he could use another one as well
even though he's walking into the Hall
of Fame that numbers count for
quarterbacks I I think Brock is such an
interesting CU it's multiple
conversations having it happening at
once with Brock with everybody just
jumping into The Fray because there is
oh he's a great story he has
outperformed his draft status he has
maxed out his physical ability he is
running this offense much better than
his predecessor Jimmy garoo for all the
people who want to say well Kyle was
able to get Jimmy Garoppolo to be a
winning quarterback in the postseason
their numbers are not really comparable
in the postseason Brock is a marketly
better quarterback especially we've seen
late in games in this postseason but
that then gets him because of the team
success into these MVP conversations
where now you're staring eyee to eye
with Lamar Jackson and Patrick Mahomes
and quarterbacks he is very much not at
this juncture as a second-year player
who was the last pick in the draft so
it's a tough eval because of that but I
hope this week we kind of do settle into
hey this pretty damn cool that this guy
has answered the bell at every turn in a
post where we didn't think the Niners
could come back and win games and he's
done it twice in games he's played bad
that's a level of Moxy from a
second-year player coming off an injury
that is wild I uh probably have to take
credit and blame for uh assigning game
manager to uh quarterbacks it started
with Alex Smith and Alex is not my
friend but that's okay um I I think we
have to change game Commander like if I
if I if I dress it up a little bit like
game manager okay it doesn't sound good
but like we we we want to change the
name of Meatloaf to something different
because it doesn't sound good you're
going to have meatloaf but if you change
it to meet Heaven you know then you know
then meet Mountain then maybe we we view
it differently so meet Mountain I like
that one yes of course yeah by the way
the meat mountain is a secret menu item
at Arby's and I don't recommend anyone
orders it I did I did it so you don't
have to thank I went down in the Arby's
coal mines for you and I came out alive
but I didn't feel I didn't feel great
about there are two things two terms
that are the fword of football game
manager and analytics analytics should
just be re redis distributed is that
information not analytics it's just
information that we digest and then
decide what we want to do by the way Dan
to your point about rebranding it
someone and I I wish I could remember
who it was and give them credit this is
not me this is Stolen Valor from Twitter
but someone called it game CEO like
you're not the manager like you're a
seite executive of this thing you're out
here wheeling and dealing so that could
be a route we go yeah yeah I I got to
get you know away from this because I I
brought this up a couple of times you
know Bart Star game manager or you know
B greasy game manager Johnny Unitus game
man Tom Brady game manager it's not a
negative but it makes it seem like
you're not talented so that's where I
get it so if we change it to game
commander game game General it's up to
you to do that you have you have the
ability I have the number one show in
America that's
all when's the last time you spanked him
when I I spanked him yeah uh two days
ago he tried last night at dinner to
take a swipe I was the one that lead dog
dessert because everyone else was afraid
of it and I'm not going to run from the
fight and I ordered this plate of ice
cream and as soon as it lands I see him
trained over in my direction and he went
and reached and I parried his spoon away
with mine deflected that was a big
moment in the fatherson dynamic all
sudden i' he just gives in and now he
doesn't anymore yeah I like it yeah uh
great to see you guys Mike Senior Mike
Jr the co-host of Gojo and gock on
DraftKings Network work we'll take a
break we're back after this in The Dan
Patrick Show